لقد ذكرت عدد القتلى وهنا في
الولايات المتحدة سُئل الرئيس بايدن في
وقت سابق عن عدد القتلى المتزايد،
وأنا متأكد من أنك فاتتك هذا لأنك كنت
تعالج المرضى الذين كنت
تعمل معهم ولكني أريدك أن تستمع إليه
ما قاله الرئيس الأمريكي
ليس لدي أي فكرة أن
الفلسطينيين يقولون الحقيقة بشأن
عدد الأشخاص الذين قتلوا، أنا متأكد من أن
الأبرياء قتلوا وهذا
ثمن شن حرب، أعتقد أننا يجب أن
نكون حذرين بشكل لا يصدق، أعتقد أننا لسنا
إسرائيليين  يجب أن نكون حذرين للغاية للتأكد من
أنهم يركزون على
ملاحقة الأشخاص الذين ينشرون
هذه الحرب ضد
إسرائيل. من الواضح أن الأرقام
تأتي من وزارة الصحة في غزة،
وحماس تدير غزة، ولكن ما رأيك
في مدى دقة ذلك؟  هل تعتقد أن
الأرقام مأخوذة مما
رأيته؟ أعتقد أن الرئيس بايدن
يخبر الإسرائيليين بشكل أساسي أنهم
لم يقتلوا عددًا كافيًا من الفلسطينيين بعد
وأن هناك مجالًا أكبر لمزيد من
المذبحة إذا كنت أعني أن هذه هي
الكارثة هنا هي أن  الأجانب
يمنعهم الإسرائيليون من
الدخول لرؤية الجثث
المتكدسة في الهضاب لرؤية المقابر
الجماعية اليومية أه التي يتم
حفرها الآن أه فقط لرعاية كل
المرضى كل الموتى الذين هم
يتم إخراجي من تحت
الركام أه عندما كنت أقود سيارتي منذ أكثر من أسبوع
من شمال غزة إلى مستشفى الشفاء
لمرافقة مريض في كل مرة
تمر فيها بالقرب من مبنى تم
مهاجمته وهدمه،
يمكنك شم رائحة الموتى والجثث المتحللة
في سيارة الإسعاف أثناء قيادتك بالقرب من المكان، كما تعلم
أنه من المقدر أن حوالي 1500 لا
يزالون تحت الأنقاض بالإضافة
إلى حوالي 6000 شخص قتلوا
177000 كما تعلم، أعني ما
وصفه الرئيس بايدن للتو، لقد
انتهيت للتو من إجراء عملية جراحية على  صبي يبلغ من العمر 13 عامًا
وهو في نفس عمر
طفلي الأصغر ولديه حروق كاملة في
وجهه في أطرافه العلوية والسفلية،
كما أن والدته تعاني من حروق شديدة جدًا في
أكثر من 50٪ من جسدها، كما تعلم تحاول
شرح ذلك ليس كافيًا  من ذلك الطفل
هناك المزيد من أنس الصبي هناك
يجب أن يكون هناك المزيد أه أه أه جريح
ومعاناة حتى تتوقف هذه الحرب
أحاول معرفة ما هي
حصة الدم الفلسطيني التي
تريدها الإدارة الأمريكية
لإجبار الإسرائيليين على
وقف إطلاق النار